because Lia I understand where you're  coming from but I feel like you haven't  acknowledged exactly what you're we're  trying to forgive you for I think you're  just saying I've been a bad person but  you're not acknowledging the kind of  invisible racism in your mind you may  not be doing it intentionally but I  think you are is still motivating your  actions the racism that is ingrained and  your behavior to the point of  invisibility is still pushing you to  behave in a certain way towards kitty  towards Eric towards me in a way that  you don't even recognize so where are  you now are you acknowledging that even  if you didn't intended are your actions  motivated by racist thoughts that are  implicit embedded in your mentality  [Applause]